parti de 2,2 points qui a priori n'ont
rien à voir mais on pourrait donner
d'autres exemples
il trouve que ceux ci sont son récent un
sociologue stéphane dorin qui a été
évincé de son groupe de travail et
l'université de limoges parce que il
s'est opposé à ce qu'on appelle les
théories des colonials c'est à dire le
fait qu' il ya un racisme institutionnel
français qu'il faut pas que
l'appropriation culturelle donc entre
guillemets qu'il faut une forme de de
repentance par rapport à tous ces sujets
un autre exemple celui d'un d'enseignant
en philosophie depuis plus de 30 ans
l'université toulouse appelle philippe
soual et en commun il a participé à
l'université de la manif pour tous il
s'est vu retirer son concours
d'agrégation
est ce que ce sont des points comme ça
qu'ils sont juste des exemples qui n'ont
pas de sens profond ou est ce qu'il ya
un mouvement
judith waintraub je me souviens qu'au
mois d'octobre vous avez consacré un
très long article qui avait fait la
couverture du figaro magazine la
pression du politiquement correct dans
l'université américaine arrive en france
en s'appuyant sur un livre de géraldine
smith qui est française mais qui vit aux
états unis maintenant et qui racontait
comment savait complètement envahi les
facs américaines est pourri les facs
américaines pourraient tous les
enseignements toutes les relations entre
profs et les ventres et élèves semaine
c'est devenu irrespirable
ça n'arrive pas en france est déjà
arrivé depuis plusieurs années les
exemples sont multiples rappelez-vous le
directeur de l'iut de saint denis
samuel bayonne qui a été d'avoir viré
et puis victime de enfin victime de
coups et blessures parce qu'il
s'opposait à l'islamisation
218 et il y avait des salles de prière
il y avait des tentatives d'intimidation
des étudiantes non voilée pour s'être
opposé à ça il a été victime de coups et
blessures et ensuite il a été mis à pied
alors que c'était lui essayé de résister
finalement réintégré mais c'est ce
qu'elle est c'est très symptomatique
autre exemple parce que c'est alors ça
c'était à sa hiérarchie qu'il avait
lâché en rase campagne
autre exemple les syndicats l'unef paris
iv qui élit à sa tête une étudiante
voilée l'unef qui se prétend à la pointe
des combats féministes enfin des
exemples sont foison la pièce posthume
de charb interdite dans les gens fal'cie
nature charge de victimes de l'attentât
de de charlie hebdo
sanaa les jours oui française prochaine
administration de faire de sciences
politiques de paris et bouteldja amis de
danièle obono et chef des indigènes de
la république autorisés à tenir un
séminaire de décolonisation au sein
d'universités françaises et cetera et
cetera etc vous renvoie le contrat
confié qu'avant c'est de très bon papier
de notre camarade alexandre ii vecchio
qui est disponible sur lefigaro.fr
christophe de voogd veut vous enseigner
dans l'un des temples du politiquement
correct puisque à sciences po
quand on est on enseignait même la
théorie du genre est ce que vous vous le
voyez progresser vous ce politiquement
correct cette pression de ne pas sortir
du discours dominant notamment sur le
communautarisme mais vous voulez ma mort
académique où ma mort tous qu un an je
ne vous veux que tu bien dans un an
en fait attention je crois qu'il ya une
confusion sur les termes
le politiquement correct très longtemps
qu'il règne à l'université c'est dire ce
qu'on appelle par là le fait de prendre
des périphrases d'éviter de nommer les
choses et c'était très longtemps que
c'est une tendance de l'université
française comme des médias français
d'ailleurs là on parle d'autre chose on
parle des théories des colonials ça
c'est plus nouveau c'est à dire parce
que là c'est véritablement c'est une
engagement militant en faveur donc des
rats 6es
par notre état raciste etc donc il a il
s'agit de tout un
c'est bien plus que le politiquement
correct il s'agit véritablement d'une
entreprise intellectuelle et politique
avisé clairement totalitaire et qui
cherchent et qui fonctionne par
l'intimidation
bon alors vous avez cité les exemples
moi je crois que ce que je vous renvoie
un petit peu la question qui les hommes
ce qui m'étonne un petit peu c'est qu'on
a beaucoup de choses beaucoup d'opinion
là dessus notamment dans le figaro moi
je trouve que c'est devrait être plutôt
l'objet d'une investigation c'est à dire
de faire exactement comment se fait-il
qu est ce qui s'est passé avec eux et
stéphane hains dorin exactement qui est
quand même été exclu de son laboratoire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé comment s'est
passée l'élection de danièle obono qu'il
a su gérer et c'est comme pourquoi est
ce qu'elle est là elle est députée bien
sûr mais pourquoi cette débuté là donc
je crois que il ya vraiment là un
travail d'investigation que moi je
serais très curieux de lire delà de la
presse des médias qui cherchent
justement et alice est encore une fois
en distinguant bien le politiquement
correct du des coloniale et ses termes
une règle parce que je vois beaucoup
apparaître sa l'influencé américaine je
rappelle tout de même que tous ces
mouvements sont nés de ce qu'on appelle
la french theory c'est à dire de nos
grands maîtres à penser
les maîtres penseurs comme derrida la
déconstruction et c'est très mal compris
très mal interprété mais peu importe
c'est toujours comme ça m'est donc je
voudrais quand même toujours rappeler
que ce mouvement est un mouvement de
boomerang et que c'est d'abord notre
grande délégation française qui a mis en
place le paradigme de commentaires après
ce que vous voulez dire d'abord vous
allez trouver assez vite sauf figaro.fr
une réponse à votre question sur cette
investigation puisqu'on travaille là
dessus pour le figaro et pas seulement
sur le site internet
et puis nicole qui nous dit l'université
devient n'importe quoi on fait encore du
copier coller sur les anglo saxons et ça
devient grave ce qui va dans votre dans
votre sens
hervé nathan ça vous inquiète spes de de
pression parce que c'est une bonne même
sens en même temps parce que quand vous
êtes très à gauche
ou alors que vous êtes très très des
colonials là vous avez là mais le
problème avec la hiérarchie
alors je j'ai concédé le point c'est
effectivement le des colonialismes me
semble quelque chose de tout à fait
dommageable pour la meilleure tout s'est
introduit dans l'université française
c'est c'est un espèce de relativisme
skin certaine manière ça combat beaucoup
d idées qui sont une autre c'était leur
universalisme si on la considère pas
dire est chose assez un peu simplement
pour nous pour nos auditeurs
les économistes considèrent qu'une femme
noire elle est bien sûr repris mais
comme femme et comme son oppresseur
c'est un noir qui lui-même est opprimé
par un blanc et ben en fait le véritable
oppresseurs de la femme noire c'est le
blanc voilà je vous résume ans je crois
que je suis pas beaucoup trompé bon nom
et ses jeux voilà c'est ça le délai que
le néo colonialisme intersectionnelle it
etc
alors bien sûr c'est alors d'abord sa
touche effectivement d'abord enfin sa
touche presque uniquement les sociale
et sciences politiques je peux
simplement témoigner moi comme j'ai fait
est journaliste économique que dans
d'autres secteurs de l'université
française
il ya des secteurs entiers où il ya
exactement inverse c'est-à-dire où les
étés au par exemple on est en économie
les théories néo classiques sont en
train de devenir quasiment hégémonique
et plus que j'aime mixer et elia jaua
monopole de la par exemple des passages
de thèses parce qu'il n'y a plus aucun
pratiquement plus aucun recrutement de
professeurs apte à diriger des thèses et
à faire partie du jury thèse qui ne sont
pas de l'école néoclassique sagna pas
les hétérodoxes et même pas les
ultralibéraux d'ailleurs c'est assez
drôle c'est quelque chose comme c'est lé
nos principes et eu du mal à être
vraiment une tribune au que le
politiquement correct en économie c'est
les néoclassiques essais excluant
certaine manière ce qui le drame
d'université c'est quand il n'y a pas de
diversité alors pour le coup c'est
terrible guillaume bernard est ce que
les théories des colonials ont droit de
cité à l'institut catholique d'études
supérieures on s'intéresse pas trop à ça
pour l'instant
mais moi je crois qu'il y a je dirais
deux enjeux il ya la question de
l'atmosphère qui règne dans le milieu
intellectuel et puis à la question je
dirais de la la science au bon moi je
crois que l'université doit être le lieu
du débat et donc ne comptez pas sur moi
pour être le censeur je dirais d'une
quelconque position défendue à partir du
moment où les critères académiques sont
véritablement remplit pas pour autant il
est bien évident que c'est là où on en
vient un ange est plus large que la
question des thèses de 2,2 comment dire
dit des colonisatrice c'est que le
népotisme l'auto reproduction la
cooptation c'est que dans un certain
nombre de secteurs
je connais pas celui de l'économie j'en
connais d'autres
mieux il est bien évident que il y as tu
dirais un système de recrutement à
l'université française qui conduit
nécessairement je dirais à et bien la
reproduction d'une pensée et l'exclusion
d'une certaine manière de ce qui
pourrait être marginaux donc par
conséquent moi il me semble que au delà
même de cette question-là de cette
idéologie là parce qu'en fait
c'est une question de définition des
mots 1 c'est à dire qu'ils veulent
redéfinir les mots pour dire qu' il n'y
aurait de racisme que si c'est un
racisme d'état
cissé leurs racines la navy lui ça n'est
pas du racisme bon donc en fait c'est un
long jeu de mots au delà je dirais de
cette idéologie là c'est tout le
problème du fonctionnement du
recrutement des universitaires pensons
par exemple aux cmu ou la qualification
qui est donné aux universitaires se fait
sans même l'audition des parties sans
même que le candidat ne puisse répondre
aux arguments contre lui donc ça ça me
paraît parfaitement je dirais d'un autre
âge soviétie forme et donc je pense
qu'il faut changer
surtout ce système là merci beaucoup
malheureusement l'émission est terminée
chaque crise aux dogmes et c'est promis
vous revenez l'année prochaine c'est la
censure du politique puisque c'est la
solution du politiquement correct vous
savez bien que d'un point de vue c'est
la règle c'est la dernière émission de
la semaine mais aussi de l'année
toutefois on ne se sépare pas avant
d'avoir donné un grand coup de chapeau à
valérie en chemin valérie c'est l'un des
piliers une des chevilles ouvrières du
figaro lac depuis le début du projet
c'est notamment elle qui était la
réalisation de points de vue alors elle
part pour de nouvelles aventures
donc on les souhaite vraiment le
meilleur et puis on souhaite aussi bon
vent à elisabeth pierre sont qui a
assumé avec talent la gestion des
invités de l'émission voilà cette fois
ci c'est vraiment fini joyeux noël à
tous et à l'année prochaine
[Musique]